Xiaomi ist überraschend mit einem
beeindruckenden neuen
Open-Source-KI-Modell zurück: Mimo
Version 2.6. Dies ist ihr nächster
großer Schritt in Richtung RSI, ein
Konzept, das sie in ihrem Blogbeitrag
hervorgehoben haben und das ich
ziemlich interessant fand. Es ist zudem
ein Modell, das auf die Skalierung von
RL setzt, also auf Reinforcement
Learning bei komplexen, überprüfbaren
Aufgaben, damit sich das Modell durch
Exploration und Feedback stetig
verbessern kann. Die Mimo-Version 2.6-
Reihe umfasst nun das Pro-Modell, ihr
bisher leistungsfähigstes Modell,
sowie Flash, das auf Geschwindigkeit,
Effizienz und Kosten optimiert ist. Es
gibt auch einen Pro Ultra-Speed-Modus,
der bis zu 20-mal schnellere Ausgaben
bei gleicher Qualität liefert. Das
hier ist das Flash-Modell und es ist
wahnsinnig schnell. Und noch etwas: Man
kann tatsächlich kostenlos über
OpenRouter darauf zugreifen. Ich werde
von ihnen nicht gesponsert. Ich wollte
es euch nur wissen lassen, da ihr das
Beste daraus machen könnt, weil dieses
Modell ziemlich leistungsfähig und
natürlich kostenlos ist. Leute,
Entschuldigung für die Unterbrechung,
aber falls ihr es noch nicht getan habt
, abonniert bitte den World of AI
YouTube-Kanal, da mir das wirklich
helfen würde und es mir natürlich
ermöglicht, jeden Tag Videos zu machen
. Gebt diesem Video auch ein „
Gefällt mir“, falls möglich. Das
bedeutet mir wirklich sehr viel. Auf
dem World of AI-Benchmark und der
Vibe-Coding-Plattform haben wir dieses
Modell rigoros getestet und
festgestellt, dass es ziemlich weit
oben rangiert. Wir fanden, dass es das
derzeit beste Modell mit offenen
Gewichten ist, das in mehreren
Bereichen glänzt. Ihr könnt dies
selbst testen, um zu sehen, wie ihr all
diese Modelle in euren eigenen
Arbeitsablauf integrieren könnt. Ich
empfehle euch sehr, einen Blick auf die
Links in der Videobeschreibung zu
werfen, da dies komplett kostenlos
möglich ist. So bekommt ihr ein
besseres Gefühl dafür, was ihr mit
diesem Modell tun könnt und versteht
auch die anderen Tools, die euch im
KI-Bereich unterstützen können. Was
bei diesem Modell aber verrückt ist:
Die Preise sind gegenüber Version 2.5
nicht gestiegen. Xiaomi behauptet, dass
das Mimo Version 2.6 Pro einen neuen
Preis-Leistungs-Rekord unter den
chinesischen Modellen aufstellt und nur
ein Zwanzigstel bis ein Sechzigstel der
Kosten führender internationaler
Modelle bei vergleichbarer Intelligenz
verursacht. Und was die Benchmarks
betrifft, so sieht man, dass es in
vielen verschiedenen Bereichen wie
Programmierung, allgemeine
Anwendungsfälle sowie in verschiedenen
visuellen und Cyber-Kategorien sehr
wettbewerbsfähig ist. Wie bei Deep
Seek Version 1.1 liegt es hier leicht
hinter den modernsten Modellen wie GPT-
6 Astra sowie anderen
State-of-the-Art-Modellen zurück. Auch
beim Program Bench erzielt es ziemlich
unglaubliche Ergebnisse. Insgesamt
sieht man einfach, dass dies ein
wirklich wettbewerbsfähiges Modell ist
, das wahnsinnig schnell und extrem
günstig ist und in vielen
verschiedenen Bereichen diese irren
Ergebnisse liefert. Sogar im
Intelligenz-Index von Artificial
Analysis übertrifft es Kimi K3 und
Quant 3.8 Max und wird zum stärksten
Open-Source-Modell, und das ist nicht
der einzige Benchmark, der das
bestätigt. Auch unser World of AI
Benchmark validiert diese Behauptung,
und es ist einfach verrückt, weil es
nah an GPT 5.6 herankommt, obwohl es
Open-Source ist, was einfach irre ist.
Sehen Sie das? Dies wurde tatsächlich
von der Version 2.6 Pro erstellt. Es
ist einfach verrückt, Leute, dass ein
Modell diese Art von Qualität ausgeben
konnte. Das ist etwas, wofür ein
Spieleentwickler wahrscheinlich mehrere
Monate zum Programmieren brauchen
würde, und in diesem Fall wurde es
innerhalb weniger Tage erledigt. Hier
zeigt sich, dass Mimo Version 2.6
außergewöhnlich gut bei 3
D-räumlichem Denken, multimodaler
Wahrnehmung und sogar Computernutzung
ist. Es ist etwas, das es Ihnen
ermöglicht, Text, Bilder oder Videos
in spielbare 3 D-Welten zu verwandeln,
wie Sie hier sehen können. Es kann
sogar Blender-Szenen erstellen, Roboter
in Simulationen steuern und
Desktop-Tools autonom zur
Aufgabenbewältigung nutzen. Im Grunde
genommen ist das
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis das, was es
vor jedes andere interessante Modell
setzt. Es bietet offensichtlich eine
unglaubliche Leistung in mehreren
Bereichen und liefert diese Leistung
gleichzeitig zu unglaublich günstigen
Preisen, weshalb Sie sich das unbedingt
ansehen sollten, besonders da die
Flash-Variante derzeit kostenlos ist.
Einige weitere Details zu diesem Modell
: Es enthält ein Kontextfenster von 1
Million Token und hat dieselben Preise
wie Version 2.5, was großartig ist.
Die Pro-Version kostet 43 Cent pro 1
Million Input-Token und 87 Cent pro 1
Million Output-Token. Und die Version
2.5 Flash kostet 14 Cent pro 1 Million
Input-Token sowie 28 Cent pro 1 Million
Output-Token. Was wir jetzt tun werden,
ist, dieses Modell zu testen. Wenn Sie
mit diesem Modell loslegen möchten,
können Sie dies ganz einfach über den
Mimo-Chatbot tun, für den ich einen
Link in der Beschreibung unten
hinterlasse. Sie können auch über
deren API darauf zugreifen. Wie ich
bereits erwähnt habe, können Sie
jetzt komplett kostenlos über
Open-Code darauf zugreifen, wo Ihnen
die Flash-Variante ebenfalls völlig
gratis zur Verfügung steht. Und falls
Sie es noch nicht getan haben, können
Sie einen Blick in die Welt der
KI-Benchmark-Suite werfen, wo Sie sogar
testen können, ob es etwas ist, das
Sie nutzen möchten. Darüber hinaus
erhalten Sie Zugang zu meiner
Prompt-Bibliothek, daher kann ich nur
empfehlen, dort einmal reinzuschauen.
Aber jetzt werden wir dieses Modell in
mehreren Bereichen testen, um zu sehen,
wie leistungsfähig es ist und was man
tatsächlich damit machen kann.
Beginnen wir mit meiner
Lieblingsgenerierung: Hier konnte Meemo
Version 2.6 Pro ein vollständiges 3
D-Spiel im Sonic-Stil von Grund auf neu
erstellen. Es hat die Programmierung
hinter der 3 D-Umgebung, die
Charakterbewegung und die Physik
übernommen–schaut euch einfach die
Qualität an, Leute. Das ist wirklich
absolut verrückt, und es gibt sogar
verschiedene Arten von Levels.
Natürlich gibt es ein paar Dinge, die
im Moment noch nicht ganz perfekt
aussehen, aber abgesehen davon wurden
das Kamerasystem, das Leveldesign, die
Hindernisse und die Spielmechanik
gründlich generiert, und es konnte all
diese Funktionen stimmig zusammenfügen
. Es ist also einfach wahnsinnig, dass
es in der Lage war, eine vollständig
spielbare Erfahrung auszugeben, die das
ursprüngliche Sonic-Spiel nachahmt.
Nun haben wir endlich ein chinesisches
KI-Modell, das nicht denselben
Designstil kopiert wie die führenden
Modelle von Anthropic oder OpenAI, denn
das Xiaomi Mi Moji Version 2.6 Pro und
auch die Flash-Variante können
ziemlich großartige Designs ausgeben,
die eindeutig ihren eigenen
Designgeschmack widerspiegeln, was man
an den verschiedenen Frontends sehen
kann, die sie in ihrem Blogbeitrag
vorgestellt haben. Ich werde auch meine
eigenen Generierungen zeigen, aber das
ist etwas, das ich einfach
unterstreichen wollte. Es verdeutlicht
den eigenen Designgeschmack mit ein
paar der verschiedenen Landingpages,
die von Version 2.5 oder 6 generiert
wurden, und insgesamt zeigt es einfach,
wie gut das Modell darin ist, diese
unterschiedlichen Ergebnisse zu
erzeugen. Hier hatte ich es gebeten,
eine Landingpage für Nvidia zu
erstellen, und natürlich konnte es
nicht jeden Aspekt wie das Logo und
alles andere exakt klonen, aber die
Tatsache, dass es diesen
Grafikprozessor mit einem 3 D-Modell
vollständig ausprogrammiert und viele
dieser interaktiven Elemente zur Seite
hinzugefügt hat, ist einfach
unglaublich. Hier sieht man sehr gut,
dass das Modell bei der Erstellung
dieses 3 D-Modells der Grafikkarte
großartige Arbeit geleistet hat, was
bei den meisten anderen Modellen oft
nicht gelingt. Deshalb gilt es derzeit
auch als das beste Open-Source-Modell,
das aktuell verfügbar ist. Man erkennt
all die anderen Elemente, die mit der
Anmeldeseite generiert wurden, die
Scroll-Trigger und die verschiedenen
Design-Nuancen–insgesamt muss ich
sagen, dass ich begeistert bin, was das
Modell mit diesen verschiedenen
Front-End-Generierungen geschafft hat.
Schauen Sie sich das einfach mal an.
Dies ist eine Live-Darstellung der
Funktionsweise des Kühlsystems bei
dieser GPU. Natürlich wirken die 3
D-Dimensionen in dieser Darstellung
nicht ganz perfekt, aber es ist cool,
diese Draufsicht auf den Lufteinlass
und den Luftausstoß zu sehen.
Insgesamt liebe ich diese Generierung
wirklich, und es ist toll, dass dieses
Modell so etwas ausgeben konnte. Wenn
Sie die besten KI-Tools, Workflows und
Neuheiten vor allen anderen erfahren
möchten, abonnieren Sie meinen
kostenlosen Newsletter über den Link
in der Videobeschreibung–das Ganze
ist komplett kostenlos. Als Nächstes
habe ich das Modell angewiesen, ein
Formel-Drift-Szenario zu generieren; es
handelt sich um eine 3 GS-Simulation,
in der ein F1-Wagen unendlich lange
Donuts dreht. Und das ist
wahrscheinlich die beste Generierung,
die ich jemals mit diesem speziellen
Prompt erhalten habe. Es wurden sogar,
wie man hört, die passenden
Soundeffekte hinzugefügt. Es gibt
verschiedene Kamerawinkel, aber schauen
Sie sich einfach die gesamte Szene an,
die hier generiert wurde. Lassen Sie
mich kurz den Ton ausschalten, weil das
wirklich nervig ist, aber alles an
dieser Szene ist einfach unglaublich,
Leute. Hier konnte es das 3 D-Modell
des F1-Wagens wirklich gründlich
generieren. Natürlich sieht es nicht
exakt wie ein echter F1-Wagen aus, aber
betrachten Sie einmal alle Details
dieser Szene. Man hat verschiedene
Kamerawinkel und den Rauch, der beim
Driften entsteht. Man sieht
Reifenspuren sowie den Wechsel in den
Rückwärtsgang und Zeitlupeneffekte.
Es ist einfach unglaublich, dass wir
diese Art von Generierung erreicht
haben, Leute, denn so etwas habe ich
bisher bei keinem anderen Modell
gesehen, selbst beim Astra-Modell nicht
. Ich bin zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass
dieses Modell bei 3 D-Umgebungen
außergewöhnlich gut abschneidet. Es
ist in der Lage, verschiedene 3
D-Pakete basierend auf dem jeweiligen
Prompt wirklich gut zu imitieren und zu
morphen. Wie in diesem Fall, wo es
diesen isometrischen Raum basierend auf
meiner Anfrage erstellt hat. Sie haben
natürlich verschiedene Kamerawinkel.
Sie haben sogar die Möglichkeit,
verschiedene Arten von Objekten in
diesem Raum hervorzuheben. Es erzeugt
diesen Effekt: Wenn Sie mit der Maus
darüberfahren, erhalten Sie eine
Bewegung und Animation, die Ihnen eine
bessere Visualisierung des Produkts
selbst bietet und sogar etwas Kontext
zur Umgebung hinzufügt, was ebenfalls
sehr cool ist. Als Nächstes haben wir
dieses SVG-Gemälde, und sowohl die
Funktionalität als auch die visuelle
Qualität dieses Ergebnisses sind
einfach unglaublich. Sie haben
natürlich die Möglichkeit, bestimmte
Dinge an diesem Gemälde anzupassen,
wie zum Beispiel die Animationen zu
ändern, etwa den sich langsam
bewegenden Baum. Es gibt sogar Wind,
Vögel und viele Elemente, die zu
funktionieren und sich zu bewegen
scheinen, was dieser Generierung
Lebendigkeit verleiht. Insgesamt liebe
ich einfach die Qualität, die mit dem
spezifischen SVG-Prompt sowie einigen
anderen Prompts, wie der Kunstleinwand
und der New Yorker Skyline, erreicht
wurde. Es hat einen ziemlich
ordentlichen Job gemacht. Insgesamt hat
es alles generiert, was wir angefordert
hatten, aber der einzige kleine Fehler,
den wir in dieser Darstellung sehen
können, sind die fliegenden Autos. An
dieser Stelle sollte eigentlich eine
Brücke die Stadt verbinden, aber in
diesem Fall nehme ich an, dass sie
über diese Gebäude gelegt wurde. Aber
abgesehen davon scheint alles andere
ziemlich gut generiert worden zu sein.
Man kann sehen, dass die Autos sogar
Scheinwerfer haben, und natürlich gibt
es kleine Animationen sowie einige
Details, wie zum Beispiel einen kleinen
Gehweg. Sie haben einen Hubschrauber.
Sie haben sogar den Mond, der dieses
kleine Licht, diesen Farbton,
ausstrahlt. Insgesamt liebe ich also
die Generierungsqualität mit diesem
speziellen Prompt wirklich. Nun,
normalerweise, oder besser gesagt in
letzter Zeit, habe ich aufgehört,
Klone zu machen, wie diese
OS-Klon-Demos, da wir alle wissen, dass
viele dieser Prompts mittlerweile von
vielen dieser Modelle kontaminiert sind
. Aber ich wollte diesen Windows 95-
Klon präsentieren, weil er ein
Detaillevel aufweist, das ich
eigentlich von Astra oder sogar Fable
erwarten würde, da er offensichtlich
viele der Kernkomponenten des
ursprünglichen Betriebssystems
enthält. Aber zu sehen, wie ein
Open-Weight-Modell so etwas generiert,
ist fantastisch, denn Sie haben die
Diskette, natürlich Ihren Hauptrechner
und viele dieser anderen Komponenten,
die die meisten Modelle normalerweise
nicht generieren. Sie haben die Tipps.
Sie können dies natürlich schließen,
aber Sie haben zum Beispiel das
Internet, das ziemlich gut
ausprogrammiert wurde. Sie haben eine
Menge dieser anderen Elemente. Es ist
einfach wirklich cool zu sehen, dass
dies etwas ist, das vollständig von
diesem Modell selbst dargestellt wurde,
und man hat sogar die
DOS-Eingabeaufforderung selbst. Das ist
also etwas, von dem ich wirklich nicht
erwartet hätte, dass dieses Modell es
tatsächlich generieren würde. Wenn
dir dieses Video gefällt und du den
Kanal unterstützen möchtest, kannst
du über die „Super Thanks“-Option
unter dem Video spenden. Oder du kannst
unserem privaten Discord beitreten, wo
du monatlich kostenlosen Zugriff auf
verschiedene Abonnements für
unterschiedliche KI-Tools erhältst,
sowie tägliche KI-News, exklusive
Inhalte und vieles mehr. Und Leute,
wenn ihr möchtet, dass dieses Modell
Visualisierungen erstellt, die euch
helfen, verschiedene Arten von
Generierungen oder Konzepten besser zu
artikulieren, dann ist dies das Modell,
das ihr verwenden wollt, da es
offensichtlich wirklich gut im
Front-End mit seinem eigenen
Design-Geschmack ist. Die
Preisgestaltung ist zudem
außergewöhnlich, was man an einigen
dieser verschiedenen Generierungen
sehen kann, wie etwa bei einem
simulierten Grafikrechner, der
Benutzeroberfläche und den
verschiedenen Detailebenen, die es
zuweisen kann. Seht ihr das hier? Dies
ist ein Simulationsspiel, das das
Modell tatsächlich erstellt hat. Man
hat die Möglichkeit, die Simulation
offensichtlich weiter zu skalieren,
indem man diese verschiedenen Arten von
Mechaniken sowie Funktionen in die Welt
einbaut, wie etwa das Hinzufügen von
Parks, Landwirtschaft und Wohngebieten.
Dies sind alles verschiedene Arten von
Funktionen, die vollständig in diese
Generierung hineincodiert wurden, und
ich liebe es wirklich, dass das Modell
diese Art von Qualität liefern kann.
Man merkt, dass es wirklich gut mit 3
D-Umgebungen umgehen kann, da hier alle
diese Elemente vollständig vom Modell
codiert wurden. Wie ich bereits
erwähnt habe, ist das
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis das, was
einen dazu bewegt, dieses Modell zu
nutzen, da es offensichtlich schnell
ist und die Arbeit zu einem unglaublich
günstigeren Preis erledigt als die
anderen hochmodernen Modelle, weshalb
man dieses Modell verwenden möchte.
Insgesamt bin ich wirklich begeistert
von diesem Modell und es ist verrückt,
dass dies nur ein kleines Upgrade von
der 2.5 er-Version ist. Wir könnten
größere Upgrades von Xiaomi sehen,
vielleicht sogar die 3.0-Version, die
es auf das gleiche Niveau wie UCPC 6
Astra bringen würde. Ich weiß es
nicht, ich vermute es nur, aber wenn
sie ein RSI-System entwickeln, eine
skalierende RL-Struktur oder ein
Framework, das ihnen beim Trainieren
von Modellen hilft, wäre das ziemlich
revolutionär, und wir würden recht
bald großartigere Modelle von Xiaomi
sehen, falls sie dieses System
etabliert haben. Aber insgesamt ist
dies ein Modell, das verschiedene Arten
von Aufgaben wie Frontend, komplexe 3
D-Umgebungen und sogar multimodale
Aufgaben ziemlich gut bewältigen kann.
Es ist außerdem etwas, das sich bei
visuellen Aufgaben im Bereich der
Computernutzung und sogar in der
Robotik sehr gut schlägt. Es ist also
ein Modell, das in vielen Bereichen
überzeugt und dabei kosteneffizient
sowie insgesamt sehr schnell ist. Das
ist etwas, das ich unbedingt zum
Ausprobieren empfehlen würde. Ich
werde alle Links, die ich im heutigen
Video verwende, unten in die
Beschreibung einfügen. Aber damit,
Leute, vielen herzlichen Dank fürs
Zuschauen. Ich hoffe, euch hat das
heutige Video gefallen. Schaut euch
unbedingt auch unsere School-Community
an, dort erhaltet ihr Zugang zu vielen
verschiedenen Vorteilen sowie
vorzeitigen Zugriff auf das Testen von
KI-Modellen. Werft unbedingt einen
Blick auf die Welt der AI Vibe Coding
Platform und den Benchmark. Schaut euch
auch gerne unseren zweiten Kanal an.
Schließt euch unserem Newsletter und
Discord an, folgt mir auf Twitter und
abonniert schließlich unseren Kanal.
Aktiviert die Glocke, gebt dem Video
ein Like und seht euch unsere früheren
Videos an, damit ihr bei den neuesten
KI-Nachrichten auf dem Laufenden bleibt
. Aber damit, Leute, habt einen
fantastischen Tag, verbreitet
Positivität und wir sehen uns ganz
bald wieder. Macht’s gut, Leute.